[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen einen schönen
guten abend diverse politische top
termine werden heute die sendung
bestimmen und auch die olympischen
spiele wieder mit gold nachrichten und
kristin otto insgesamt ein turbulenter
tag und nacht hier sind unsere themen
krisendiplomatie in russland ukraine
konflikt kanzler scholz ist er in
washington
annalena baerbock in kiew und die
verteidigungsministerin schickt weitere
soldaten nach litauen
notstand wegen corona protesten
demonstrierende lkw fahrer legen die
kanadische hauptstadt ottawa
und zweites deutsches gold in china bei
den olympischen winterspielen des
biathleten denise herrmann die
schnellste
[Musik]
krieg verhindern frieden bewahren darauf
lässt es sich reduzieren wenn ab heute
mehrere staats und regierungschefs sowie
hochrangige politiker beraten es geht um
den konflikt zwischen russland und der
ukraine weiter gefasst um den konflikt
zwischen russland und der nato und die
alles entscheidende frage wie lässt sich
ein krieg im osten europas noch abwenden
der vielleicht wichtigste schauplatz
heute das weiße haus dort empfängt der
us-präsident in wenigen minuten
bundeskanzler scholz in die ukrainische
hauptstadt kiew ist erneut
außenministerin baerbock gereist und in
moskau da sucht frankreichs präsident
makro den dialog aber zunächst zum
antrittsbesuch des kanzlers in die usa
aus washington jetzt benjamin daniel
dass man hier nur fluggeräusche und
nicht etwa den kanzler sprechen hört hat
seine richtigkeit
hintergrundgespräch mit journalisten auf
dem flug nach washington
es ist alles andere als der usa routine
antrittbesuch den sich ein neuer
bundeskanzler wünschen könnte die reise
überschattet von der ukraine krise
scholz äußerte sich noch vor seinem
treffen mit joe biden es wird einen sehr
hohen preis haben wenn es dazu kommt
dass die ukraine militärisch angegriffen
wird und wir bereiten das auch präzise
vor und sind seit langer zeit dabei die
details dazu zu besprechen denn es geht
ja dann darum schnell zügig und
entschlossen zu handeln und vor allem
einheitlich amerika scheint nicht sicher
zu sein was es vom neuen bundeskanzler
halten soll das liegt auch am
zögerlichen verhalten berlins in der
ukraine krise während die usa tausende
truppen entsenden und waffen liefern bot
deutschland bisher 5000 helmer an dass
die verteidigungsministerin just heute
verkündet 350 weitere soldaten nach
litauen zu schicken ist sicher kein
zufall
und dann gibt's mit nord stream zwei ja
noch die dauer differenz zwischen den
usa und deutschland
außerdem weitere wichtige punkte dann
gibt es natürlich auch um die enge
ökonomische zusammenarbeit zwischen den
usa und deutschland und natürlich auch
darum wie wir die große weltweite
aufgabe bewältigen den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
da gibt es viel zu besprechen gerade im
rahmen der g7 präsidentschaft die
deutschland jetzt hat der bundeskanzler
wird in wenigen minuten mit dem
us-präsidenten im weißen haus sprechen
sie werden also viele themen diskutieren
ganz oben steht nicht weniger als der
frieden in europa
das treffen im blick hat elmar theveßen
in washington für uns immer teile der us
politik sehen den deutschen russland
kurs ziemlich kritisch wie wird scholz
das bild gerade rücken worauf könnte
worauf wird es gleich hinauslaufen
also er muss starke signale senden dass
deutschland wirklich ganz dicht an der
seite aller verbündeten steht da hilft
natürlich dass jetzt 350 zusätzliche
bundeswehrsoldaten nach litauen sollen
aber das wird hier in washington auch
ein stück weiter als selbstverständlich
angesehen für ein nato partner der die
ostflanke der nato für den fall einer
invasion schützen will es gibt kritische
fragen denen er sich stellen muss der
bundeskanzler zum einen warum ein land
das 9 milliarden euro in rüstungsgütern
weltweit exportiert und unter anderem
auch länder wie ägypten beliefert warum
das nicht in der lage ist mehr
beizutragen zur selbstverteidigung der
ukraine und zum zweiten vor allen dingen
nord stream zwei der bundeskanzler hat
das wort bisher nicht in den mund
genommen sondern spricht immer alle
optionen liegen auf dem tisch er sagt
das sei strategische uneindeutigkeit
damit putin nicht genau weiß wie viel
bezahlen muss wenn er in die ukraine
einmarschiert das sieht man hier im
weißen haus ganz anders man sagt es muss
klarheit herrschen wie hoch der preis
für wladimir putin ist nur dann kann
abschreckung wirklich funktionieren
vielen dank nach washington elmar
theveßen und was genau beim treffen
zwischen kanzler und dem us-präsidenten
besprochen wird das können sie sich live
anschauen die gemeinsame pressekonferenz
gibt es bei zdf heute live ab 21 uhr
beziehungsweise in unserer app und auf
unseren social media kanälen scholz in
den usa außenministerin berbalk in der
ukraine auch dort wird der deutsche
krisenkurs kritisch gesehen keine
waffenlieferungen wie von kiew gefordert
und unklar was mögliche sanktionen gegen
russland angeht keine einfache
ausgangslage für annalena baerbock die
binnen drei wochen schon das zweite mal
in der ukraine ist axel sturm fast
zusammen bei ihrer ankunft in kiew
dürfte die deutsche außenministerin
schon gewusst haben dieser besuch wird
schwieriger als der letzte deutschland
soll liefern waffen nämlich vor dem
hintergrund des russischen drohszenario
sun der grenze die weigerung der
bundesregierung versteht man hier nicht
mit hinblick auf die ukraine halten wir
diese haltung für unfair wir glauben
dass deutschland mehr handlungsspielraum
hat
es gehört nicht unbedingt zu
diplomatischen gepflogenheiten unter
freunden einen besuch vorab mit
forderungen zu versehen wie das bier box
amtskollege heute tat aber es ist keine
neue forderung die da aus kiew kommt
hier an der gedenkstätte für die große
hungersnot die stalin in den 30er jahren
über die ukraine gebracht hatte ist
symbolpolitik erwünscht aber nicht im
aktuellen konflikt mit russland
wir stehen ohne wenn und aber zur
territorialen integrität
und souveränität der ukraine und diese
durch solidarität will ich mit meinem
besuch heute hier noch einmal
unterstreichen und ganz deutlich zum
ausdruck bringen dass wir alles dafür
tun werden dass es zu keiner weiteren
eskalation kommen würde der bock spricht
über sanktionen über einigkeit über
waffen spricht sie nicht in moskau wird
auch gesprochen englisch
view wie geht es ihnen sagt makro fein
sagt putin hatten sie eine gute reise
sehr gut makro hatte vorab für die frage
russlands nach seiner sicherheit
verständnis gezeigt sagte aber auch es
dürfe bei der souveränität der ukraine
keine kompromisse geben
krisendiplomatie in moskau und kiew
heute bislang ohne ergebnis die deutsche
aussenministerin reist morgen weiter in
die ost ukraine
und an die kinder ist er ist für uns in
kiew er begleitet die außenministerin an
die es geht ja bei dem besuch nicht nur
um diplomatie sondern auch um
deutschlands rolle und ansehen in europa
wie wird das wahrgenommen
werden unterschiede wahrgenommen in der
art der kommunikation denn der
politischen performance auf der einen
seite die auffällige reisetätigkeit die
dramatische wortwahl von frankreichs
präsident makro der heute in moskau ist
morgen vormittag in kiew sein wird und
morgen nachmittag in berlin und auf der
anderen seite die ja etwas langsameren
deutschen die hier auch immer so ein
bisschen den eindruck hinterher reisen
zu spät zu passiv zu sein und da soll
diese reise da sollen diese tage die
wende bringen ministerin berg will
morgen in die ost ukraine fahren dann
die sogenannte kontakt linie das wird
hier in der ukraine sicher für aufsehen
sorgen und danach wird es in berlin eine
ganze serie von großen und kleinen
gipfeltreffen geben an denen auch
russische diplomaten teilnehmen und das
signal senden dass deutschland den
erwartungen an deutschland gerecht wird
vielen dank nach kiew an die gunners war
das also wird sicherlich spannend morgen
wenn der bundeskanzler scholz auf
frankreichs präsidenten makro trifft in
berlin jetzt komme zu corona
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
rechnet damit dass einschränkungen
deutlich vor ostern gelockert werden
können das sagte er der bild zeitung
hier sind die aktuellen zahlen dem
robert koch institut wurden 95
1267 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden gemeldet
16949 mehr als vor einer woche
49 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage instituts steigt auf
1426 experten gehen allerdings von einer
hohen zahl an erfasster fälle
auswahltest kapazitäten und
gesundheitsämter vielerorts am limit
sind und weitere interessante zahlen und
analysen finden sie bei uns auch online
zum beispiel daten zur aktuellen lage in
den krankenhäusern
aufgeschlüsselt nach bundesländern unter
zdf heute und in unserer zdf heute
zu den verlierern der pandemie gehören
ganz sicher auch schülerinnen und
schüler weniger präsenz stunden und
damit weniger sozialkontakte stattdessen
viel lernen zuhause
defizite sind jetzt schon sichtbar ein
drittel der kinder und jugendliche hat
deutliche lern rückstände davon gehen
lehrkräfte laut einer umfrage aus es
baut sich ein immenser bedarf an
nachhilfe auf heißt es von verbänden
mehr jetzt dazu von anja klingen aus
düsseldorf die fünfte klasse der
realschule friedrichstadt in düsseldorf
auch hier sind es vor allem die ohnehin
schwachen schüler die nachhaltig unter
den auswirkungen des pandemie bedingten
online unterrichts leiden
[Musik]
es wird mir gemacht hat könnte ich das
halt auch gar nicht weil es viel
schwieriger sind und deshalb auch
schlechtere noten lerndefizite die einen
regelrechten ansturm auf
nachhilfeinstitute auslösen vielerorts
gibt es wartelisten und täglich neue
anfragen schon eine herausforderung
damit das auch funktioniert sind wir
natürlich auf der suche nach weiteren
lehrkräften nach weiteren kollegen aber
wir versuchen möglichst schnell den
schülern zu helfen und sei es dass wir
mal eine schüler mehr pro gruppe
unterbringen und dennoch kommt es zu
wartezeiten mancher orts monate lang
doch die zeit drängt denn vor allem in
den fünften und sechsten klassen mangelt
es an basiswissen das in der grundschule
verpasst wurde unmöglich für die schulen
das nachzuholen immer wieder sind viele
kinder in quarantäne schnelltests rauben
wertvolle unterrichtszeit und der
lehrplan drückt auch noch
wir haben also nicht extra zeit um das
was nicht gelernt werden konnte
aufzuholen sondern wir haben das problem
dass eigentlich weniger zeit zur
verfügung steht umso wichtiger nach
hilfe als ergänzung zum schulunterricht
möglich auch für kinder aus
geringverdiener familien kostenlose
nachhilfe über das bundesweite
förderpaket bildung und teilhabe heute
wichtiger denn je
und das kam für viele heute überraschend
die unionsparteien machen eine
kehrtwende bei der impfpflicht für
pflegekräfte cdu-chef märz fordert von
der bundesregierung darauf zu verzichten
und ministerpräsident söder kündigte an
dass bayern erst einmal nicht mitmache
und begründete das auch mit befürchteten
engpässe beim personal
das gesetz sieht eigentlich vor dass ab
mitte märz beschäftigte einen impf oder
genesenen nachweis vorlegen müssen
scharfe kritik kommt von
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach es
gehe um den schutz von heimbewohnern
aber auch um die glaubwürdigkeit von
politik
in kanada legen trucker also lkw-fahrer
seit tagen große teile der hauptstadt
ottawa lahm ihre wut richtet sich gegen
die korona beschränkungen der regierung
unterstützung kommt aus dem nachbarland
genauer vom ehemaligen us-präsidenten
trump der bezeichnete premierminister
trikot als linksradikalen irren der
kanada mit wahnsinnigen corona maßnahmen
zerstört habe oder was bürgermeister
rief angesichts der trucker blockade
jetzt den notstand aus mehr von reiff
schipanski
konserven klopapier sie haben was nötig
ist um durchzuhalten
nach wie vor haben die jogger aus vor
dem parlament laut und in der absicht zu
bleiben werde tausende demonstranten
ausging ein paar hundert polizisten dann
sind wir unterlegen und wir müssen klar
machen dass recht und ordnung in die
stadt zurückkommen als
die trucker durchs land zogen wurden sie
durchaus auch gefeiert und inzwischen
ist das was man anfing als protest gegen
im vorschriften für grenzpendler mehr
sie wollen dass alle kroner maßnahmen
fallen
diese regelungen müssen ein ende haben
wir bauen folgsam wir haben zwei jahre
unseren job gemacht aber jetzt ist es an
der zeit wir wollen unser leben zurück
warum sind andere länder auf und wir zu
gibt uns unsere freiheit lasst uns in
ruhe
mit ausrufen des notstands will die
stadt ottawa hilfe vom staat und den
druck auf das camp erhöhen denn längst
nicht alle anwohner sympathisieren
sie könnten sie daran hindern dass sie
hier parken das überhaupt in die stadt
gelangen
ich habe vor drei wochen meinen job
verloren ja und ich verliere den
verstand wegen euch
die fronten sind verhärtet die
relationen aber eindeutig 77 prozent der
kanadier sind vollständig geimpft die
mehrheit ist für strenge maßnahmen allen
protesten zum trotz
hass rede im netz ist ein riesenproblem
das auf worte taten werden können hat
nicht zuletzt auch der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten lübke gezeigt
insofern muss man alarmiert reagieren
wenn jetzt wie nach dem mord an zwei
polizisten in rheinland-pfalz
internetnutzer die mutmaßlichen täter
sogar als vorbilder feiern über die
vielen verachtenden und grenzwertigen
hass kommentare die die ermittler
auswerten und den umgang damit bobby g
m2
bullenschweine weniger sind halt eine
gute nachricht sollte öfters vorkommen
auf solche aussagen im netz ist die
ermittlungsgruppe hate speech des
landeskriminalamtes rheinland pfalz in
den vergangenen tagen zuhauf gestoßen
399 registrierte fälle von hass und
hetze nach der tötung zweier polizisten
im kreis kusel
102 haben wir schon die bewertung das
ist strafrechtlich relevant da wird dann
weiter ermittelt und damit muss jeder
und jedem klar sein du kommst nicht
automatisch durch wenn du meinst du
könntest so etwas posten in 15 fällen
habe die ermittlungsgruppe bereits
verantwortliche ermitteln können aus
virtueller wittwer der reale gewalt hieß
es heute das legen auch zahlen des
bundeskriminalamtes nahe die politisch
motivierten straftaten gegen amts und
mandatsträger sind in den letzten vier
jahren um fast 200 prozent gestiegen
diese gesamtentwicklung kann durchaus
demokratiegefährdend sein wenn menschen
sich nicht mehr trauen ihre meinung zu
äußern oder ein amt zu übernehmen
die gewalt gegen den staat sowie seine
vertreterinnen und vertreter nimmt zu
hier helfe nur konsequente bestrafung
und aufklärung beim ausklang geht es
natürlich darum sehr deutlich zu machen
bereits schon in der schule wo die
grenze zwischen einer schützenswerten
meinung und einem hass posting verläuft
was wir als gesellschaft nicht mehr
bereit sind hinzunehmen und auch die
folgen für die betroffenen aufzuzeigen
die tat von kusel wirkt noch immer nach
die ermittler wollen jetzt klare
botschaften senden wer straftaten an
polizeibeamten billigt und opfer
verhöhnt wird ebenfalls bestraft mit bis
zu drei jahren haft
ob einfamilienhaus oder bezahlbare
wohnung für jeden der bauen will wird
noch teurer vergangenes jahr stiegen die
preise um sechs prozent so viel wie seit
20 jahren nicht mehr dieses jahr kommen
voraussichtlich noch einmal 4 prozent
hinzu so der zentralverband des
deutschen baugewerbes
preistreiber ist vor allem das bauholz
aber auch stahl und dämmstoffe wurden
deutlich teurer
wir sind jetzt bei olympia und wir haben
uns überlegt jeden tag jetzt eine
super aber heute gab es war keine
riesenüberraschung
biathletinnen denise herrmann hat das
kunststück vollbracht auf den punkt der
bestes leistungsvermögen abzurufen
fokussiert auf dieses einzelnen bei
olympia gewannen sie nach einem weltcup
winter mit rückschlägen olympisches gold
einfach nur grenzenloser jubel nach
ihrem glänzenden auftritt die
überraschende krönung einer bislang eher
durchwachsenen saison für die 33 jährige
denise herrmann gold im biathlon über 15
kilometer ihr traum ist wahr geworden
der traditionelle wettkampf und dass ich
da hat jetzt das geschafft habe macht
mich unglaublich stolz und glücklich und
da helfen auch die wurde mit nur einem
schießfehler beendet die
oberwiesenthalerin ihren fast
fehlerfreien durchgang bei guten
bedingungen mit weniger wind beschert
der deutschen mannschaft das zweite gold
silber geht an die französin an esche
wally boucher und bronze wo die
norwegerinnen marke als böse land für
denise herrmann ist das nach olympia
bronze mit der langlaufstaffel 2014 ihre
erste medaille im biathlon und dann noch
die goldene
zwei tage nach ihrem silber sprung wut
und fassungslosigkeit bei katharina
althaus denn durch ihre disqualifikation
schied das deutsche mixed team aus
tränen beim mixed wettbewerb im
skispringen katharina althaus
disqualifiziert wegen eines nicht
regelkonformen anzug ist das aus für die
zuvor in aussichtsreicher position
liegen den deutschen auch athletinnen
aus japan norwegen und österreich sind
von disqualifikationen betroffen wir
sind alle stocksauer weil die mädchen
sagen unisono und die sind alle die
gleiche anzüge gesprungen wie im
einzelbewerb
und dort alles gepasst vier top nationen
somit ohne jede chance auf medaillen
gold geht trotzdem man einen favoriten
die slowenen um einzel olympiasiegerin
bugatti silber und bronze holen sich die
teams aus russland und kanada
zuversicht bei den deutschen rodlerinnen
sie liegen auf gold und silber kurs
natalie geisenberger führt nach zwei von
vier läufen vor teamkollegin anna
bereiter weltmeisterin julia taubitz
muss dagegen diesen schlimmen sturz
verkraften der ihre chance auf einen
podestplatz zunichte macht körperlich
ist sie aber soweit wohlauf und
erleichterung bei den alpinen die nach
einigen verschiebungen gestern wegen zu
viel wind ihre ersten entscheidungen
endlich austragen konnten
wertvolle aus dem emmental spitzname
kugelblitz ist olympiasieger in der
königsdisziplin gewinnt abfahrts gold
für die schweiz vor dem franzosen johan
clarey und matthias mayr aus österreich
bester dsv athlet romed baumann auf rang
13 dominik schwaiger stürzt bei hohem
tempo erst diagnose unterarm und
ellbogen prellung im riesenslalom der
frauen siegte die schwedin sara hector
silber holt federico prämie für italien
bronze lara gut behramis der schweiz
einzige deutsche reiter platz 21
favoriten michaela schiffen aus den usa
scheidet bereits nach wenigen toren aus
und noch einen paukenschlag aus der
fußball-bundesliga niklas süle wechselt
von bayern münchen zu borussia dortmund
einen vierjahresvertrag
absolut das ist wirklich ein
paukenschlag allerdings an geschirr
christin und apropos den gab es auch
beim wetter weil letzte nacht war
einiges los gewittersturm regen schnee
später dann auch noch glatteis sturmtief
roxana hatte einige überraschungen im
gepäck zur wochenmitte soll sich das
wetter vor allem im süden aber wieder
beruhigen
katja horneffer hat gleich mehr details
um viertel vor zehn bringt sie marietta
slomka im heute journal auf den neuesten
stand und wir vom 19 uhr team sagen
danke entspannten abend und gerne bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend in den vergangenen zwei
tagen zeigte sich das winterwetter von
seiner garstigen seite es gab viel regen
es gab es gab sturm und sogar orkanböen
und gewitter dazu gab es auch einige
lawinenunfälle in den alpen auch jetzt
am abend schneit es noch am alpenrand
und auch in der nacht erwarten uns noch
weitere schneefälle hier im osten
bayerns oder auch im thüringer wald
sonst ist es meist bedeckt und hier und
da fällt ein bisschen lägen die
temperaturen sinken auf plus fünf bis
minus sieben grad und liegen dann morgen
über tag zwischen 4 grad in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen und 12 grad am
niederrhein das wetter dazu ist im
wesentlichen zweigeteilt im norden es
ist eher bedeckt und nordöstlich von
weser und elbe kann es auch regnen im
süden ist es freundlicher besonders am
alpenrand und am oberrhein in den
nächsten tagen wird es in süddeutschland
sehr freundlich sei mit viel sonne und
es ist sehr mild bei 6 bis 13 grad über
norddeutschland aber ziehen regenwolken
entdeckt am freitag aber dreht der wind
auf nordwestliche richtung es wird
deutlich kälter und bei temperaturen von
zwei bis acht grad mischen sich dann
auch im flachland schneeflocken unter
den regen guten abend